this is a legendary place of your
biologists I mean camp leakey has this
reputation as one of the foundations of
biology camp leakey is the wild around
the town research count that I
established 40 years ago i named it non
er Louis Leakey he was my mentor
shooting in this film we spent a lot of
time with larger orangutans that are
have been rehabilitated by breeding all
the costs and her staff and so these
might be ringing tones that are now 30
years old that have been living wild now
for 20 years you know they're familiar
with the human world you know they even
though they live in the jungle they'll
come visit the research station now
pookie is the one place on this planet
where great apes and humans are truly
equal in the late 90s the forest
surrounding camp leakey was getting
crowded with rehabilitated orangutans so
in 1998 dr. gahl decoste opened the
orangutan Care Center a facility that
now cares for 330 orphans the main thing
that we give them is the ability to
explore as rehabilitate themselves in a
safe environment under the watchful eyes
of kind caregivers
the Iranian towns at the care center
range from probably two weeks old to
seven or eight years old they go through
their infancy a toddler stage they
really go through every stage of
development that we see in human
children the orphans live at the care
center until they reach the age that
they would no longer be dependent on
their mothers in the wild they crave the
physical contact cuz that's what her
orangutang does in the wild as it clings
to its mother like velcro because she is
the only protection it really has once
they reach a stage where they can
survive on their own they know how to
forage they can make nests and the trees
then we will release a small group of a
rabbit runs back to the wild
kappa mikey is now back to being a
research station but it's at the heart
and soul of everything that we do here
in the RiverClan care center
Oh
Oh
a